some of your favorite local chefs are
coming together this thursday for a
taste of red rock it will be a culinary
event hosted by red rock lifestyle
magazine with proceeds going towards
three square food bank and joining us
today is the publisher of red rock
lifestyle christine lindell along with
three score president and ceo brian
burton and one of the participating chef
chef sonia thank you so much for joining
us today you guys this is fun i am so
excited about this event now christine
tell us a little bit more about it
because this is going to be if you are a
culinary fan this is the place to be oh
thank you so much well we appreciate you
having us on the show today um red rock
lifestyle is a magazine and our back
cover sponsor is land rover jaguar they
agree to host the event which when you
throw events the venue is a pretty big
expense yes the other big expense is
food and drinks and all of these chefs
have come together they are amazing
their camaraderie is cool they're some
of the hottest talked about chefs and
chef sonia is with us today and so we're
just so excited to bring the event we
have it asking for an 80 donation um and
thanks to three square right now is our
holiday hunger drive so that's going to
get matched yeah let's talk a little bit
more about that brian this event it
comes at a perfect time because three
square you guys really need
those donations right now yeah we're so
honored to be a beneficiary of this but
you're right during the holidays we have
corporate matching
donors and so every dollar can create up
to six meals so
as we're enjoying this delicious food
we're feeding those one out of six
people in our community who don't know
where their next meal is coming from how
does it feel to have the community
support
of events like this it makes me
emotional because this community has
raised this food bank stayed with us
during the pandemic and our agency
partners that are out there on the front
lines every day feeding
hundreds of thousands of people it's
just incredible but this event is really
going to give us a boost so we
appreciate the chef and christine it's
going to be a lot of fun and chef sanji
let's be honest you're the star of the
show that's right there's many
many you're one of the stars and you are
creating culinary dishes all the chefs
are going to create different things
tell us what you are going to do i chose
to make vegetables because um dan's
doing
fish and no he's doing meat i don't
everybody's doing something different so
i chose to do vegetables
i made baba ghanoush now if people don't
know what baba ganoush is first of all
get on it's delicious tell everybody
what it is it's an eggplant that is
broiled and then i mix it with tahini
and salt and olive oil and garlic a
little aleppo pepper i did these carrots
with
this fantastic brand of harissa that's
done locally also and what
isa is a chili
paste sauce that's really delicious
mostly it's from the
northern african okay so middle east but
north africa and then we have the
organic carrots and then i did greens
look at this solid this looks so it's
really good it'd be great um so it just
has olive oil and balsamic vinegar it
smells so fresh can i taste one of these
carrots of course and everything comes
from intuitive forager who's carrie
clasby who has donated all our produce
for this
this is going to be an incredible event
i know who's table i'm going to okay
this is fantastic thank you you can get
your